[Music]
my name is coby magnesia I'm a product
manager for gk google kubernetes engine
and i have the pleasure to have here
with me Josh Hoch Zac Laughlin and
Daniel Loretto we are going to speak
about non-trivial challenges that we
have with managing Jiki at scale and
managing different releases of
kubernetes at scale in the gk fleet what
can you expect from this session today
one we are going to start with just a
quick overview of google kubernetes
engine the way we manage the different
building blocks of kubernetes in the
fleet - we are going to speak about some
challenges those challenges present some
limitation but also entice us to think
about different ways we can simplify and
streamline the release process for you 3
we are going to speak about kubernetes
at scale how do we take an open-source
kubernetes version and funnel it through
the power engine of Chiqui and make it
available for you four we are going to
speak about tools and capabilities that
we provide you so you can manage your
risk and you can manage your clusters
and then 5 lastly we are going to share
with you some of the upcoming features
that will give you more flexibility and
control over the G key releases in this
Google next event we also introduced a
new capability so the door Q&A you
probably seen it in different sessions
feel free to open your app the Google
next app you can find the link to the
Dory QA under our session you can submit
questions now or after the session we're
also going to have two microphone here
and you can ask your question using one
of these microphone we have a moderator
here that will help get the question
that you post online and so after this
session we'll go through some of this
question so let's start with a quick
introduction into gke Josh cool thanks
Coby
so I work on fleet management and a lot
of along a lot on the releases so I'm
gonna first start with what is G ke I
know you've heard a lot about kubernetes
but just so everyone's on the same page
I'm gonna talk about a little bit about
kubernetes in in google kubernetes
engine right so I said two things google
kubernetes engine is a cloud service
it's that box within a box and then you
have kubernetes which is a container
management system you might have heard
it orchestrates container is it and
typically when I think container I'm
thinking like docker containers and I'm
thinking things like rollback and
deployment and scheduling and stuff like
that so in Google cloud sorry Google
kubernetes service is a Google cloud
service just like and many of them are
Google cloud services and you can
interact with it with a via the API COI
or UI so but kubernetes is like a
heterogeneous thing and when I think
about kubernetes it has two big parts it
has the kubernetes master and it has the
kubernetes nose and the kubernetes nodes
are where users one run workloads and
then the kubernetes master is where we
run the all the little tiny pieces that
make up the kubernetes control plane if
you will that manage kubernetes so we
Google are in charge of managing your
master and you are in charge of managing
your nose and there's many different
things you can do for your nodes you can
opt into node Auto upgrade but
ultimately it's your responsibility
so after you've created a cluster now
you have something that you can interact
with and you can interact with cube
cuddle and you can create pods and
deployments and so on or you can you
know use the API so I'm gonna pass it to
Zack and Zacks going to talk a little
bit more about the internals of
kubernetes hey thanks Josh so as Josh
alluded to I'm gonna give you a little
look under the hood for kubernetes this
is super basic but the basic kubernetes
architecture
is that you have these containers as
Josh said these are doctor containers
you have pods which are collections of
these containers nodes that those pods
are running on that then talk to a
master which controls the cluster and it
uses that CD as its backing store but
that simplistic view hides a fair amount
of complexity of things that we manage
for you under the hood we run almost 50
different docker images on the master
the slide is just a sample
they include obvious things like the API
server you're familiar with you might be
familiar with a cube API server here at
CD we run all of those on top of cubelet
but they also include other things on
the master like support pods for logging
and monitoring and metrics networking
scheduling etc we also manage the
software that runs on the nodes
including the OS image and cubelet and
as part of the master version which
we'll get into in just a little bit we
manage a series of add-ons this includes
support for logging and monitoring of
your pods and also things like sto and K
native as well and on the nodes as
obviously your application as well
running on on top of our OS image and
cubelet and now I'm gonna pass it over
to Coby do talk about some of our
challenges here Thanks so kubernetes is
indeed a very powerful framework and
platform it's basically a micro services
framework built on top of micro services
pretty awesome but with all this large
set of building blocks we face the
challenges of coordinating and
qualifying different releases going
through these specific challenges I
think it will help us understand kind of
the reasons and the drivers we have to
simplify the process for you guys
so kubernetes is or kubernetes community
is a super engage community it rides
lots of code changes
this in turn translate to
quarterly releases of the open source
kubernetes version on top of those
quarterly released version there are
patch versions which include some bug
fixes and there there is also gke
releases orgy key patch releases which
includes basically the magic glue that
we have to integrate kubernetes with the
GCP infrastructure which then in turn
allows you to use GCP capabilities
through kubernetes for example you can
use GCP preemptive LVM as pre-emptive
LVM under kubernetes cluster in this
specific example you can see the amount
of version that we basically support in
the fleet right now so if you open up a
g-cloud command line and query basically
the list of versions that we support and
you can actually ask for a specific
region you will see what version we
support for the nodes and what version
we support for the master in every
specific geographic allocation so that's
one definitely one challenge having this
amount of versions to support the other
thing that we need to take care of is
the version skew policy so the open
source kubernetes policy supports two
minor versions so let's take one 14
that's the latest version when one 14
becomes available in the market
the official support would be for one 13
and one 12 however it doesn't really end
there as you probably remember from the
explanation we just got from Josh and
Zack there are two main components for
every kubernetes cluster there is the
master and there is the node and each
one of them you can have different
versions
obviously we encourage you and we want
our customer to have the same version in
both the master and the nodes but the
supported version skew allow notes to be
up to two minor versions older than the
master in the next challenge
the final one probably the more crucial
one our security fixes and obviously the
sense of urgency to roll out these
security features security patches is
higher especially when there are some
like the one we just
experience last December so you don't
need to lean forward to I know it's kind
of an eye chart but in this case there
was a security issue with the kubernetes
api we patched it and we quickly quickly
roll it out to the entire cluster so no
action was actually required from our
customers if you use G key you benefit
from the rollout of these patches in
these cases in the security issue cases
GK team will do their best to identify
resolve and patch the entire fleet and
your clusters as well to keep your
workload safe and secure for G key as a
managed kubernetes service we strive to
remove that level of complexity that I
just described and how we deal with all
these challenges josh is going to give
us some details cool so really you know
when I think about release in of
kubernetes in gke I'm really talking
about how do we get the open source
software into google kubernetes engine
and I see it as having like five main
phases so the first phase is a is the
open source release happens and I'm
gonna light a lot of stuff here but the
open source release is quite complicated
so I mean there's a whole process of
release qualification and you have to
write release notes and all the I don't
know Karina's has these special interest
groups that are sort of federated way
that features are created and all these
people have to get together right so but
from my perspective working on gke you
kind of wait for that process to finish
and then boom they come out with a new
version then we import that version into
internally and we start applying our
patches on top of that after that then
we qualify the version and this is like
can be quite a long period of time
sometimes weeks or months depending on
what the version is and then we at some
point we're like okay it is time to
release a new version let's cut a
release candidate so we caught a release
candidate and then that period is about
a roughly two one to two weeks and then
we roll it out to production of course
assuming everything works perfectly and
then once it rolls out to production we
actually have a four day rollout
so if we roll it out to a couple
locations first and a couple locations
next and then well cup more than a
couple and then we gradually do all the
locations and we try to put this all in
our release notes and of course these
days might not happen like sequentially
we might pause it if we find an outage
and then you know fix the audience
before we proceed on but it's this is
sort of the sequential order so why do
what are we releasing so when you see
like oh we're releasing a new version of
kubernetes this is kind of what Coby was
getting to you know that we have this
these four different version numbers so
we got the minor version we have the pac
kubernetes patch so those both come from
upstream and then we have the GK
specific patch which is what we're
adding on top and what corresponds to
that this is this is kind of our
identifier for the software this is the
collection of software that we release
but you know the last image cube API
server cubelet logging whatever so it's
a very important number so and remember
we have two versions we have the master
version and we have the node version and
those are separate again because of this
shared responsibility where we own the
master and we are serve in charge of
that I mean you can upgrade your master
if you want on your own but we will do
it eventually for everyone if you wait
and then there's the nodes which you can
opt-in to note auto upgrades but
ultimately it's your responsibility and
we have to sort of manage manage these
things so and that gets into upgrades
like how do we upgrade the fleet for
both the masters in the nodes and Zacks
going to talk a little bit about that
cool thanks most of the users of gka you
experienced our release process during
upgrades whether it's a master upgrade
which we initiate or whether it's a node
upgrade which you have the option of
initiating yourself or managing through
us so first let's talk about the Masters
Master upgrades are managed and like I
mentioned typically initiated as part of
the GK release process workloads running
on user nodes just stay running during
the master upgrade process when we
upgrade the control plane we also
upgrade all of our managed add-ons as
well
so as you can see in this picture the
the master is upgraded along with the
versions for stok native and as I
mentioned before all those logging and
monitoring and metrics support add-ons
all while your user application is
running so how do we do it we upgrade
zonal masters in place by creating a new
master with new software then we shift
the disk and network over and we kill
the old master we do this for this
pattern for zonal masters for regional
masters where there are 3h a masters
running we do a very similar pattern
where we spin up one more master and
then we kind of roll through doing a
rolling update on the masters so node
upgrades node upgrades are a very
similar process but they're more visible
to you in gke today you can actually
choose who manages to node upgrade and
I'll get in more into that in a little
bit but if you have no daughter upgrade
turned on you we will initiate the node
upgrades for you and if not you'll
initiate them yourself so how does a
node upgrade work well it's actually a
very similar rolling update process what
we do is we create a new node at the new
version we cordon off and drain the old
node we the the workload shifts
scheduling to the new node and then we
kill off the old node this actually
isn't exactly right
what I just showed you was a feature we
have coming up soon called surge
upgrades where we will actually give you
the capacity for one more node as you're
doing the upgrade currently the the way
the picture works is we cordon and drain
a an existing node and
then add that back in after we've
deleted it so over to Josh to talk about
the version lifecycle cool so like you
might be wondering like why do we have
so many versions and part of that is
just the natural life cycle of the
versions and really this how it relates
to this upgrade process so I'm gonna
first talk about minor version versions
of kubernetes and even though it's in
many ways the minor version is kind of a
major version but it's it's sort of the
feature version of kubernetes because
that's what most people care about all
right so what does it look like in my
head and how do how do we sequence this
well normally what happens is when we
release a new minor version there's a
period of time when it's a new version
and that what that means is it's
available for you to choose to use but
it's not not default and so you can use
this to you know use new features for
GPUs or TPS or whatever at some point
after about maybe a quarter we decide to
make that the default we're like okay
we're pretty sure that this is a solid
enough version for the entire fleet of
gke clusters and then when we shift over
the default to the next version now we
start to phase out the old minor version
of kubernetes so that now so now that
gets into upgrades when do we do
upgrades we do this in the phase-out
period so during that third period of
time is when we start to do the master
upgrades and we upgrade everything
that's no longer that was the default
but is no longer the default to the new
default sometime after that we upgrade
the nodes to the new node version for
those customers that have the node auto
upgrade enabled and patches work very
very similarly except the the phase is
much much shorter so typically for a
patch it's we're not talking about the
order of weeks rather than quarters and
so we release a new patch and then we
migrate people over and it sort of
happens in rapid succession because
patches are our bug fixes and and less
invasive
and and that's about it for the version
lifecycle so now gonna pass it over to
Coby to talk about how you can manage
your risk so now that you have
visibility into kind of the behind the
scene process of how we release
kubernetes
in a strategy we have I think it's
important to know what controls you have
today control that enable you to manage
risk and also control the disruption I
would say the first thing that might be
pretty obvious but for Inspira is key
for us and actually we want to make sure
that we provide you with visibility into
our release scope the schedule and the
life cycle our release notes include
more than just change log we actually
publish information about upcoming
versions the lifecycle of diversion
versions that we are duplicating and
even more than that I think I saw
someone taking a picture before of the
release Skadden's in different regions
we actually publish it that's part of
the release notes so if you go into the
release notes you can see exactly the
four days rollout schedule and in which
region we are releasing version first
and kind of get more information that
you can use to plan your kubernetes
clusters yeah as Kofi said like picking
a location is important you know the day
one zones happened first and typically
the big outages if they happen which
hopefully they don't we catch them in
day one and day two zones and end
regions
additionally like like I was alluding to
and maybe you figured out like it's
important to think a little bit about
which version you're picking I mean if
you want the latest and greatest
kubernetes features or you know Google
cloud features that come with the new
version of kubernetes on gke you know
choose the latest version but we are
very careful about only setting the
default when we think it's the right
time when we think this is the the
version that the majority of the fleet
should be on
while you're thinking about the version
another configuration to think about is
no dotto upgrade as I alluded to earlier
either you can manage your node upgrades
yourself or you can have us manage them
with no to upgrade enabled anytime that
we do a master upgrade shortly after we
will upgrade all of your nodes as well
we highly recommend you enable this if
you if you don't it's your
responsibility to stay within the the to
minor version skew policy that we have
the node auto upgrade feature is
actually default now in the cloud
console which is the example you'll see
on the right and it will soon be due the
default in G cloud as well in addition
so we take various automated actions on
our clusters and we recognize that some
of those actions like node upgrades
might cause disruptions to your workload
or carry some risk associated with them
so if there are times of day that might
make more sense for you to perform
upgrades you can configure maintenance
windows to stop automated actions on
your cluster for those windows and
there's an example for how to configure
a maintenance window up here and more
documentation and now over to Co V
before to talk about customers so with
with that in mind I invite Daniel to
share more about their experience as G
key customer and tell us more about
their products and their business needs
Thank You Koby my name is Daniel I'm the
head of engineering Alberta and so I
wanted to share with you how we use G
key or why we chose it as our runtime
platform but first let me give you a
little bit context about Verta where
does a company that provides essentially
continuous remote care for diabetes and
so we use technology to be able to
provide that 24/7 care to our patients
we have clinically proven results and
through technology we can scale that
treatment to lots of patients
providing care through technology is a
challenging area we need to maintain a
doctor-patient relationship through
technology as synchronously many of our
customers are very risk-averse
we're dealing with healthcare people's
lives and health are at stake and so you
know downtime or about could have
serious adverse effects and we're
working in a very heavily regulated
industry with regulations such as HIPAA
so part of why we choose gke as a
runtime environment is because it makes
some of our concerns easier GCP is a
high trust certified platform that's an
important certification in healthcare
and a lot of those controls were able to
inherit and we have a shared
responsibility model where we're able to
meet the necessary regulation in part
thanks to the help that Google provides
security updates super important for us
and the fact that Google can do that for
us takes a lot of that burden away so
that our engineering team doesn't have
to worry about it and making it making
running a Jiki cluster easier
essentially we move a lot removes a lot
of operational costs so our engineers
can focus on business needs as opposed
to maintaining the infrastructure that
said there's also challenges we've
experienced particularly around managing
all the different gke versions so for
example sometimes we want to have the
cutting-edge version in certain clusters
so our developers are experimenting with
that latest version but a more stable
version in production sometimes we wanna
we're ready to roll out a certain gke
version to production so we have a
pre-production cluster and we have to
manage that upgrade of versions all the
way to production and we want to be
fairly careful also with with the
windows in which we do this so we
mentioned earlier there's a maintenance
window feature but today that allows you
to specify for
or windows in which you want about the
updates we love a little bit more
flexibility with that for example
avoiding avoiding it during weekends or
sometimes we just sign a customer and
we're gonna have a big spike of patience
and so we'd like to avoid upgrades
during that window and so back to Kobe
who is gonna talk about how those
challenges relate to a different
customer personas thank you so we just
we just heard from Verta and thanks for
sharing your experience with us
evidently one size doesn't necessarily
fit all even though we're talking about
managed cloud service different
customers have different needs and I
want to share with you some other
examples I'm sorry so we heard about
Verta we actually created some customer
persona to represent different needs
from different type of customers so in
this case customer a they have a
specific multi weeks certification
process for every release and they have
to go through that process and certify
that's released before they roll it out
into production they're using GK today
and they are looking to align their
internal certification process with the
GK releases another example would be
this customer they upgrade today
manually so even though we have then
other upgrades option they decided to
upgrade manually because they want
better control and they want to make
sure that they understand what they get
in every release they are definitely
excited about the ability to test early
version of kubernetes and get better
time to market with new capabilities and
in this case this this type of customer
customers see they are pretty
self-sufficient they they know
kubernetes pretty well they feel very
comfortable with it they want to adopt
new feature quickly and maybe even be on
the bleeding edge version of the of
kubernetes but I also want the ability
to manage different environments and and
maybe have different type of versions in
each one of these environments so with
this example in mind we are excited to
share with you some of our upcoming
capabilities that will one provide you
more control and flexibility and two
will allow us to cater to different type
of customer
an exciting feature we have coming up in
q2 is release channels release channels
will allow you to subscribe your cluster
to releases that match your release
cadence and risk profile keeping the
Masters and nodes together at the
channel that's just right for you our
goal is that every change is qualified
in an earlier channel before it moves to
a later channel so for example any
change that made it to this regular
channel would have been qualified
previously in the rapid Channel soon
will release the rapid Channel or you
can expect the latest and greatest
releases later this year we will follow
with the regular channel bundle and
qualified pieces from the rapid Channel
with a stable channel soon after we
expect that most of you will want the
rapid or regular channels but if you
need our most stable but least feature
full releases the stable channel is for
you there's a simple example here soon
you'll be able to create a release
channel cluster as straightforward a
command line is just saying release
channel rapid and we'll follow with
cloud console changes later too and
you'll get a cluster whose master nodes
are maintained at the newest release
that we've qualified internally and for
gke this will be available later this
quarter
hopefully cool so this is something I'm
very passionate about one of the things
that I've been working on is is the
release and as part of release channels
we want serve more granular releases at
least internally and we've been making a
lot of new tooling and infrastructure
and some of that's provided in this new
open source repository we created called
the cluster bundle so if you're curious
kind of like how we think about
releasing components like definitely
check it out what is that gonna mean for
customers you won't see it directly but
you'll see it in the form of more stable
releases improved time to market and
better release notes
so in addition to release channels we
just discussed release channels allow
you to inform us with your risk appetite
and kind of the type of version or
release do you want to subscribe your
cluster to we also want to support you
in managing your risk or your miss risk
mitigation plans and canary cluster can
help with that
so canary cluster will allow you to
designate a cluster for canary or
staging tests and link it or map it with
your production cluster or clusters in
turn what we will do is GK will sequence
new version rollouts to canary clusters
first and we'll give you some time to
run your automate test make sure that
everything works nothing breaks with a
new version and once you greenlight that
version we will roll out the new version
to production the other thing we are
going to do as an alpha feature coming
up from product is an enhanced
maintenance windows which we just spoke
about so right now with maintenance
windows you can specify four hours in a
day in which that we will respect and
will will trigger maintenance events
only in these four hours but we do hear
from other customers that there are
other use cases that they want us to
support for example if you prefer to
prefer to avoid upgrade during weekends
because you are a gaming company and
most of the traffic you get in is
actually during the weekend you will be
able to use enhance maintenance windows
and set the specific days that you want
us to avoid those upgrades or those
maintenance events other use case might
be you are a retailer and you want to
make sure that we don't disrupt you with
any type of maintenance events during
Black Friday Cyber Monday so you'll be
able to set to specify a range of dates
that we will respect and we will avoid
maintenance windows happening in in in
these dates and that the last use case
is let's say you know about upcoming
upgrades but for some internal reasons
you need more time to get ready for that
specific upgrade we will allow you to
postpone or snooze the upgrade for a
specific amount of time to kind of give
you more flexibility and getting ready
for consuming the upgrades
so just to bring all of this together
because we definitely spoke about a lot
of things in in this session our goal is
to keep your cluster up and running up
to date while delivering a
non-disruptive experience for for York
for your customers and for your clusters
we aims to provide a hassle-free managed
service that's only on one side and the
other side is we're trying to balance
that with give you more controls for
flexibility if you are interested in any
one of the feature that I just mentioned
that we spoke about today please follow
that link over there and let us know
that you want to join one of the alpha
programs that I mentioned your feedback
is highly appreciated as with any other
session so after a decision and after
we're done with the Q&A please take a
moment to go through the app and share
your experience with this session
[Music]